die kandidatin der fdp fraktion für den
vorsitz im innenausschuss im
gesundheitsausschuss und im
entwicklungsausschuss von den übrigen
fraktionen nicht bestätigt wurden ist
nicht nur ein bruch mit den
parlamentarischen traditionen sondern
ein fatales signal auch für die
demokratische kultur in unserem land das
recht drei vor ausschuss vorsitzen zu
stellen ergibt sich aus dem ergebnis
eine demokratische durchgeführten
bundestagswahl weiterhin regelt die
geschäftsordnung des deutschen
bundestags und ich zitiere aus dem
paragraphen 58 der bestimmung des
vorsitzenden und seines stellvertreters
zitat die ausschüsse bestimmen ihre
vorsitzenden und deren stellvertreter
nach den vereinbarungen im ältestenrat
und genau diese vereinbarung gab es auch
im ältestenrat es handelt sich hier also
nicht um eine wahl prozedere diese war
und ist hier auch nicht vorgesehen
gewesen wir haben es hier mit dem
willkürlichen bruch einer
parlamentarischen tradition zu tun mit
dieser systematischen
ausgrenzungspolitik gegen die afg
fraktionen damit gegen millionen von
bürgern die von der a4 repräsentiert
werden untergraben die übrigen
fraktionen aus rein parteipolitischen
kalkül das vertrauen in unsere
demokratischen institutionen das von
meiner seite
dem kann ich mich nur anschließen
wir kennen das spielchen jahr der afg
fraktion wird ein sitz im
bundestagspräsidium verwehrt der
bundestags-vizepräsident gestellt von
der af die wird seit vier jahren nicht
gewählt ist jetzt zweimal durchgefallen
und nun hat man die nächste stufe
gezündet das sogar die uns zustehenden
ausschussvorsitze
uns verwehrt werden und das obwohl wir
eine repräsentanz im bundestag haben und
eben auch millionen von wählern
repräsentieren das ist ein bruch der
demokratischen teilhabe die uns als
bundestagsfraktion zusteht
professor wolfgang schröder wieso
wollten die ampel parteien den wichtigen
innenausschuss der afg den überlassen
das ist ein problem das nicht aus der
vergabe der ausschüsse ergeben hat und
das bedeutete die ausschüsse haben
zunächst mal von den parteien den
zuschlag bekommen die sie selbst als am
bedeutendsten einschätzen im hinblick
auf ihr eigenes personal also wen haben
sie und wer passt zu welchen ausschüssen
das große dilemma über das wir hier
sprechen ist dass es in den 70 jahren
bevor die afg ins parlament gekommen ist
ja eigentlich nie ein problem war die
ausschüsse so zu besetzen wie das dem
parlamentarischen gepflogenheiten
entspricht das ist zum problem geworden
in dem maße in dem eine partei im
parlament ist die nicht die achtung vor
den gepflogenheiten praktiziert die
keine zweifelsfreie demokratie
kompatibilität besitzt und damit gibt es
die angst dass der ausschuss vorsitz der
eine besondere möglichkeit zur steuerung
des ausschusses hat der über besondere
informationen verfügen kann der
besondere zugänge hat und der das
gesicht des ausschusses ist dass der
daraus kapital schlagen kann dass er
diese position missbraucht und daraus
entsteht diese computer hätten sie weil
das afg führung um in den ausschuss und
gesundheitsausschuss bedenken gehabt
ja hätte ich gehabt und zwar in
zweierlei richtung beim innenausschuss
ist ja auch anhängig die frage der
verfassungsgemäßen ausrichtung der
parteien und es gibt seit einem jahr
eine bemühung des verfassungsschutzes
die afd daraufhin zu überprüfen
inwieweit sie verdachtsfall ist und da
gibt es möglicherweise eine
interessenskollision
und es gibt auch weitere
sensibilitäten die hier zu
berücksichtigen sind und dann ist es
auch so man muss ja das parlament auch
als einen vertrauensfrau bezeichne
verstehen und das bedeutet auch dass die
abgeordneten selbst und eigenständig
darüber befinden können inwieweit sie
das vertrauen in die jeweils
präsentierten positionen haben beim
gesundheitsausschuss kommt die ganze
dimension zum tragen dass die afg ja
nachweislich
mitorganisator der anti corona
demonstration ist dass sie nachweislich
hier eine irreführung der bevölkerung in
fragen der medizinischen
abwehr strategien zur bekämpfung des
corona wiese bios praktiziert und
insofern gibt es hier kein vertrauen in
die person die diesen
gesundheitsausschuss anführen möchte wie
bewerten sie vor diesen hintergründen
das abstimmverhalten über die
vorsitzenden der ausschüsse
also ich kann dieses
abstimmungsverhalten nachvollziehen und
es ist an der afg diese zweifel
auszuräumen in denen sie ihre politik so
ausrichten dass es keinen zweifel an der
verfassungstreue an der vertrauensbasis
und an der einsicht in die notwendigkeit
oder bestimmte aktivitäten gibt und wenn
das der fall ist wird es ja auch in
zukunft die möglichkeit geben die als
steak in solche positionen einzubeziehen
und solange das nicht der fall ist das
gute recht der abgeordneten sich hier
entsprechend zu artikulieren vielen dank
professor wolfgang schröder nach berlin